[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
why are you carrying that this way
that doesn't need to come with us then
why did you bring that two or less
three it's three you were wrong well you
went through the wait mark how did you
just do that what
uh yo there's definitely gonna be a
horde wait no no wait i wasn't i was
just looking you said there was another
door in here and i
didn't put my sentry down all right
let's do it
oh try and support the wave projector oh
we're good we combed up the door
i've got the wave projector
you're fine you're fine can't spread oh
i found it guys it's here
whoa my god you're super full hey my god
this is probably it boys okay well here
i go all right
you got it oh there we go
how far back are we
i don't know me morphing through the
door just turning on the fog machine
there's one close left
oh you're on it yeah oh he's awake he's
awake get him
go you got him you got him
all awake where is he
there you are
oh on me in my soul
i can't see [ __ ] okay we're good we're
good literally nothing happened we just
turned it off
yeah it's just air
that i think right
hmm
i'm having a spasms
ah
i got double fog before it went away uh
oh there's stuff down here we didn't get
well there's a lot there's lockers oh oh
snap
resupply
disinfection
whoops sorry do you need a hand there
buddy no listen i'm so infected i wow
got more med pack where's all the
disinfection maybe i should query for
disinfection wouldn't there be a station
yeah in an old version there definitely
was i don't know about now though
let me look at this computer here
let me look at this pewter
where is the builder oh wait this is not
the way there's guys here moving full
speed
this is where spike head is at maybe i
could put it here and that would
that would be beneficial but there's
more guys that would you said yeah no
careful there's guys don't go in there
don't go in there
where are we going i can't remember
we're going at the top of this room
north
uh no we go down and then go up in the
middle of it
so you got to go down
my turret this other door over here that
we just came out of what are you guys
talking where are you guys i know okay i
was confused which room i was in i see
it now there are no disinfections cool
kind of sucks all right i'm here hey
i don't know man
i know dude i'm [ __ ] lost i'm
terrible at this this is why i follow
people around i don't know where the
hell things are why is my turret over
there god damn it who are you and where
are you there you are right here god
damn it he literally put his turret on a
goddamn staircase right here wait why
don't you watch this
here what does you do i don't know
here but it's right there that's why we
thought we were in the right place
because yeah
no where's my turn
mark it's it's it's east of you still
east of me you go up here northeast of
you oh that's right yeah you guys still
need help getting down there i [ __ ]
yeah
right here is not any more descriptive
your name is invisible in the [ __ ]
fog okay
your green name is fog colored
i'm just gonna wait what we should do is
just when we get to a circle we put down
our turrets and when we move we pick
them up that's what we should do good
yeah i think that's the only way well
the first time we go ahead and prep for
right it was down here somewhere
yeah i don't know where to see foam
sticks staircases mark they came from
these two staircases yeah at the bottom
of one you put yours to the bottom of
the other i'll put put them at the top
because that way they can see him from
farther you boys ready
yeah let's make it happen
[Music]
okay well we're definitely all here and
ready to go let's do it doesn't even
start here it does not matter okay it
was all the way down here right no is it
here yeah it starts here right at the
top of these stairs wow we found it the
next one is uh
one person can do it i think
uh
[Music]
getting overrun need to reload
i got you
ow
thank you
uh
my side okay picking up my turret we
gotta move your turret out
it was
i don't know if they came from over
there or not but i'm putting one down
coming far side
the pings are the direction they're
coming from mainly
you can move
oh it's all right behind you guys oh my
god i'm stuck i'm stuck i'm stuck i'm
down
oh there's reloading full team standing
right they're all here
i'm getting mark
okay
this is a full team one downstairs okay
come in you gotta come in as soon as i
can go
i'll catch up
coming i don't know what i just pinged
but there's a bunch of them okay
yeah yeah both directions right now
they're here
wait if you walk out in front you gotta
crouch
[Applause]
hey next next circle
oh god i'm getting overrun
i'm down i'm down oh my god
oh
good god there's like two primary doors
they're coming from we should put the
sentries there right away
yeah you probably
okay
i really do be infected
yeah i i queried there were no
disinfection packs i've got a med pack
does anyone need medpack use okay
technically what we should do is if we
have an extra med packs we should go up
to 100 anyway because our health will go
down but it goes down gradually right
true well we should wait till right
right when we're starting of course this
is what i needed where's the wave
projector i brought it which door should
be centering this one and this one
technically there are three doors coming
in
bob you were pinging them do you did you
get any sense of where they were coming
from where's the where's the bridge
we start here
and then we go down to like the middle
of the bridge wherever the bridge is
they were coming from
like that and like that to like where we
were on the bridge
so i can't really tell if they were
coming from the bottom middle door or
not i guess
but they came they they came around in
that pattern a lot from the sides i'm
gonna i'm gonna make a guess because i
remember them coming down this staircase
um that i'm at right now
i'm just gonna make a guess put mine
there because it covers one of those
entrances to this area and it covers a
stairwell
and hopefully it'll do something there
you go i have a belief in us
all right i'm healthing up else up
starting go
boys here's the hope in our centuries
yeah please sentry do something good
they're going by my sentry book oh yeah
i got one
nice
all right
there's a bunch coming from the left
yeah they're coming from the right doors
and seafoamed here
reloading
okay looking good this side a lot of
them
yeah yeah a lot on tron side
i got a lot a lot
now
okay okay almost done 95 one more one
more
maybe maybe two more maybe two move it
oh god damn
oh gee
oh burst is going i hear that
these guys
[Music]
right where these dudes were a welcoming
party
all right coming from behind us now
thing is out
reloading
okay they're dead circles done behind
behind behind buckle's gone
move to that circle
team team on downstairs yeah
move and shoot most of them they're
coming and they're coming my way they're
coming from me
oh that's someone else
50 60 70 80 almost done
done
next one's gonna be real close big ping
big ping
okay
figures in quantity yeah
reloading
big ping coming in circle's done
they're following
yep
are you gonna be right at the top of
these stairs
shooting and moving
god damn it [ __ ] off
i'm gonna help you
stragglers
this one's done
done okay where's it going i'm gonna
ammo pack myself it's going back up the
stairs towards the central all right do
you have more ammo packs
i have two more uses who needs ammo full
team
coming in right now
thank you
reloading m-o-n
reloading
[Music]
now
reloading
there's one trimming i can't see it's
not uh on the left far back i'm going to
try and big shooters
yeah big guy uh where where were
back left
[ __ ] christ
one big shooter dead yeah other side
shooter dead
back in the dark
back
bigs
the stairs ow [ __ ]
thing is out
that's a lot
oh my god
no no that's not it that's not enough
that's not it don't relax don't relax
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm gonna go get myself boys
oh it's a checkpoint um
yeah let's go get our we're gonna go get
our sentries real quick and then come
get that all right i'm gonna get out of
the checkpoint
oh no
oh wait
isn't this not good i thought this was
going to be the i thought yeah
it's just transported to wave or to 86.
so there's some kind of teleporting
thing that happens oh no
oh no
i wish we could save it here and come
back yeah i know who needs help still i
got one use
uh i'm at 37. uh mark yeah technically
i'm at 40 so are you guys lower than
that i i bet it'll resupply there's no
way it's not going to resupply us
right there's no way
yeah just get you get over wait i
thought we were here oh wait it's still
coming wait come on
notice how i was here after getting my
sentry gun like i got it i went back for
help for us but i'm now going to use on
you you a-hole well you know i bet we
got a whole eye my instinct says there's
a whole room stop pointing that drill in
my head
[Music]
my god look at all the lockers they're
full of goodies glow sticks
the power of the sun yes it was guys
it should be illegal to give you that
this late in the level hey i got a med
pack oh jewel refill god these would be
great if we weren't infected yeah they'd
be real sick if we weren't infected
there's got to be like a disinfection
station somewhere in here but whatever
all right wade you've been carrying it
for so long slam it home okay here i go
[Applause]
i don't like the sound of that we should
sketch six tools okay be careful you can
fall off the map here okay newly noticed
it's good to know i'd really love an
ammo pack of some sort
i don't like how much space there is to
move here hey look i'm out there yeah
i've got uh two
uh boxes on me um there is a staircase
that goes down
ammo i've got ammo on me too five use
oh hell yeah i can't i can't pick him up
well you probably use it on yourself
i i have a two use on me more ammo more
ammo so feel free to use that there's
more emerald down there this definitely
seems like we're going to be doing
something
yeah
disconnected what oh is this
disconnected no it's your map it's your
map
that scared the [ __ ] out of me wait
where do we go
so with the terminal we need to use this
back up top where we started i'm
assuming putting in the command will
trigger the fun times oh there's a ton
of stuff over there as well
yeah there's oh my god
three more boxes over here
guys i found disinfectant
i'm lying i just wanted you to be happy
for a second wow it was fun though right
well it lasted we're sadder now than we
were before
yeah a lot of times builders have to
tear us down even further that was kind
of inevitable
dude i hate how many boxes there are
okay yeah though this feels really good
like hold on hold on hold on
don't do it yet
hold on
i'm gonna
assume okay so this is my gamer instinct
really pinging in there's a big void
with a lot of these platforms kind of
aiming towards the void i'm guessing
something big is going to appear right
there in the vault probably something
yeah kind of big and voidy yeah
is it going to be your mom
i said that i think there's going to be
some big monster in the middle here my
gamer instinct's really kicking in guys
some kind of voidy monster yeah right
you're right you're right you're right
oh there's even more boxes up top okay
so keep note of her [ __ ] is all right
well i'm gonna have to use it i'm kind
of camping out over here i'm gonna until
i see otherwise i'm going to be right
here while all this ammo is that will
have to do with scan though
oh you're right god you're always right
you're so [ __ ] right
i'm coming i'm coming do it but i'm
coming
we're going to see a big void creature
aren't we i guarantee it's some big bass
like dead space thing sometimes i'm
doing it i'm ready oh here we go
i'm sure this will be fine spears out
lights off
i'm overhealing
oh yeah yeah yeah if you're carrying i'm
gonna heal myself real quick yeah smoke
him if you go
i'm so stupid sorry we're all healed up
baby
the void thing is happening
guys oh
that's big
my sentry is mad at it
what do we shoot at oh my god what can't
you shoot at
what
what are we doing
is it working gray i got gray
a bubble at the top oh there is a bubble
at the top yep i see that
this is what the ammo is for boys
unleash hell
okay my sentry is not really doing
anything staunchest bubble yeah it's
gonna happen
it's gonna burst it's getting darker all
right yeah
you sniping it oh
what's he doing now i think we beat it
we won right good job boys
should probably be with people huh
i'm off on my own i'm with you sean help
me
wade
you with me
oh my god
jesus wow what
those red things
if you have a med pack it'd be a great
time to hear he's hitting me yep
oh he's
glowing wow
get under something
oh
there's no roof here
it's down here the tumor's down here my
sentry is oh [ __ ]
okay oh god damn it can we can we not
see it from here
it's right here
oh oh i see it what the hell was that
oh wow i'm getting hit by something
yeah he's shooting oh he's just randomly
flinging [ __ ] everywhere it popped
up we got
hide from the guy from the bed sean
right here right here is safe right here
safe from the reds oh my god
they're flying guys
oh my god
right here
anywhere nearby
yeah we have some there's one
okay i'm looking quick i thought yeah i
got a health up here i'm good
i think there's more oh my god oh my god
there's a lot of flyers right now you
guys oh god give me some fly i'm glad i
have sea foam
yeah dude i'm glad we filled that up for
you
oh my god they just don't stop
they're never ending
ow oh my god
[ __ ]
give me that
[ __ ]
some of these guys are posing out in the
air
i'm gonna try to tour it in some place
that i can start popping some of these
flyers there we go that's going to be
broken on my screen
wasted loads of ammo on them i see the
tumor it's up where
[ __ ]
okay
it's hiding it's popped what's happening
on us
tumor is still there as far as i can get
on ammo
do you need ammo no i have one i i was
just gonna offer you
this is the third
okay cool
that's uh the last last phase last phase
maybe rule threes you going down you're
going down
no he's not
no
red red red red lasers
red leather yellow leather
oh this is red lead better i'm sorry or
yellow red feathers bread bread for the
mother not the time floyd mayweather
you can fly through walls and [ __ ] that
doesn't seem very fair what is that
oh god the reds the reds are coming
through holy [ __ ]
do you think this is how they felt when
they were trying to get america free
the rockets red glare yes this is the
reds
this is this is how the founding fathers
must have felt you're right hey who's
got the who's got the hp
the mortars are coming the mortars the
waters are coming
oh my god
oh no okay you're good on good on ammo
good on ammo still need help does he
have a pimple yet there's no health down
here i can go looking for some pimple
right side who knows
that's not how this guy
low right
it's angry it's an angry zit
looking for l running he's spawning more
flyers he's spawning a lot more flyers
oh god oh my god not enough ammo to
fight flyers and shoot the pimple yeah
i can bring you ammo that's what i was
asking
i thought i had enough i don't have
enough oh sean can you help me clear the
flyers on the right side there's so many
i'm trying
oh my god artillery [ __ ] oh [ __ ] come
for me i'm wrong wait we have ammo
oh yeah yeah back in the game okay i'm
coming
no we're good we're good we're gonna
keep fighting keep fighting keep
fighting oh god thank you
i think sniper should deal with pimple
yep the pimple is popped the bible is
gone
oh he's firing
lots of flyers coming in that's so many
flyers holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm running i'm running i'm at 15
percent ow
i need to heal a mortar mortar mortar
cover cover cover oh god i'm out in the
open oh god oh god oh god oh god
[Music]
i'm going to put sniper shots on it
i'll just try to focus on flyers
wait where oh he's blowing he's blowing
for water
yep good cover cover cover maybe
is it popped
no i'm firing though i'm firing
oh wait
what is that artillery no it's reds red
spread threats
the cincinnati reds are coming
unless it's in the middle of the map
that none of us are right do we have
eyes on us did anywhere i don't think so
i don't see one no there's here bob
there's more behind the border
i'm coming get under something
isn't that great
oh
okay thank you very good thank you thank
you
coming in flyer i've got one health pack
here i'm going to leave it on that shelf
same shelf sean i would do we have any
eyes on the zit nothing knows it i see
nothing so he knows it
it might be lower he's glowing uh more
more tomorrow
oh cover
if you uh my sniper sentry could you do
something about this surely is a pimple
up by now
oh yeah what's going on here i'm not
seeing anything right or something
yeah i got nothing over here
going i'm going to look close
oh this is a bad idea
oh the golds are coming i'm retreating
no pimple no pimple at all okay i think
i'm in cover
oh please mortar fire yeah mortar what
about the wait the database the
objective
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] download the gina i'm
going i'm going i'm going to these
videos okay oh okay yeah that would be
good
from here sean how do we get down from
here why is it coming to me it's coming
to me
jump down this
i see there's
oh [ __ ] no that's where marcus okay yeah
yeah you were right you were right you
were right fly boys ah ow ah hey wade
how you doing hey i'm great oh my god
i'm terminally and cover me
uh doing my best my turrets over there
girl logs query lists
there there's i can't do anything
download genome database from alpha one
there doesn't seem to be anything that i
can do make sure you're covered all
right there's gotta be something
to hit on him then i'm gonna head down
or there's more ammo and stuff yeah i'm
gonna switch positions here i'm gonna
grab my turret i'm gonna come upstairs
see if i see something differently
autogen status
just trying to shoot random things see
if anything happens
oh
oh god oh god oh god don't go down
not like this don't hit me please don't
hit me please don't hit me
please don't hit it
here they come they're coming for bob
jesus christ
oh i need to regen health but i'm not oh
god emergency blood
oh god they're all down here
list query ping long three
there's there's i can't do anything
there's nothing to do i don't understand
did he bug ah
do we do we get things if we shoot him
if we just shoot his tentacles or
whatever
grey
yeah i tried spraying him a bit he
didn't seem to do nothing oh my sound is
bugged
yeah that's kind of happening to me on
and off the sound just being really bad
i have no gunshot sounds yeah let me
hear
oh there's a tumor bottom right
oh son of a
[ __ ] oh i'm gonna go down i'm gonna go
down i'm down god damn it okay i'm
coming for you uh oh yeah
get him
god damn it
are you good are you good getting mark
still yeah
did you get the pimple oh
that popped god damn it
now he's done oh
there you go
bye [ __ ] bye
oh
holy [ __ ]
i thought i was playing monster 130
minutes ago not right now
[Laughter]
hey there's a med pack here
now we can download the database i'm
sure ah
righty roo
[Music]
oh
huh
well good job
i have no game audio oops
well let's just extract before something
comes and kills us
i'm bolton follow me i know the word
quick way out uh now i'm a little lost
but i know the quick way out follow me
all
right so glad there's so many people to
follow
oh my god you gotta be joking me
set it up you gotta be yanking my cord
holy [ __ ]
we did it oh my god three and a half
hours jesus christ oh my god
we didn't even die that many times on
that
one oh yeah
well that was fun but
that was awesome
i'm late
okay yeah no thanks guys so much that
was awesome
you